hello everyone myself shivam kumar i am
from btech biotechnology i'm from amity
university nueda and topic for my study
is investigate epigenomic factor
landscape to categorize tumors for early
diagnosis and patient treatment
stratification
intrusion as we all know cancer is a
very dangerous disease and there are
many research going around the globe to
find a perfect cure for cancer that can
fully cure a cancer but only it's up to
research only and as you know cancer is
not a single step it is a multi-level
process and
they they might occur due to some
external or environmental factors are
there they can occur without any cause
highly exposure of carcinogen to the
body might cause cancer in the human
body
bioinformatics is a very important and
helpful tool in analyzing cancer and
treating with the help of bioinformatics
and traditional methods to cure cancer
it might be possible to fully cure a
cancer in this
theory of cancer in this study we will
learn about various various comics data
to get hand on some tools that can be
used to study cancer
there were three courses required to
complete
uh to study to complete my project those
were genomic epigenomics introduction to
bioinformatics
introduction to bioinformatics
techniques like christian medicine and
personalized medicine help in improving
health care system around the globe
molecular diagnostic detects specific
sequence in dna or rna associated with
disease
the finding of molecular features that
could be used in diagnostics is often
done with the help of bioinformatics
the use of big data to discover new
medicine is still in public stages
bioinformatics offers a wide range of
possibilities from genomes and
transcriptomics for target
identification to proteomics and
structure
structural biology for small molecule
optimization we can optimize treatment
regime from the start by applying one
formative instead of going through the
costly and time consuming trial and
error discovery process
bioinformatics is an indisciplinary
display that includes biology computer
science statistics and more as discussed
discussed in introduction to big data
and politics we discussed big data
information and justification in
fundamental research healthcare and
businesses
uh bioinformatics is also helpful in
agriculture agri genomics attempts to
find new solutions to challenge arising
from environmental stress such as
climate change while also promotion
promoting the development of sustainable
productivity for the world's growing
population
the importance of genetic engineering
and biotechnology enhanced breeding
trading in culture is one of the most
significant contrast between agriculture
and bioinformatics application plant
breeding includes altering native genes
whereas genetic engineering involves in
inserting a foreign gene into an
organizing organism it resulted in
better yields reduced pesticides drought
resistance and improved nutrition among
other advantage engineering
engineered organisms for features like
stress resistance and nutritional value
necessary are true graph of target
organisms genome and the use of foreign
gene as a starting point
introduction to genomics a genome is a
collection of dna that makes up
organisms genetic materials genomics is
the study of genomes which includes dna
sequencing and data analysis techniques
the size of data files including genomic
sequences is frequently in gigabiting my
information on the development of
computer methods for the study of
genetic data the massive data element of
genomics that it sets it apart from
genetics in most cases genetics entails
sequencing and researching especially
genes and their function in inherited
traits
because the sequencing and analysis of
complete genome present significant
significantly different technical and
computational problems than genetic
genomics stand out
there are three types of genome
sequencing the first one is targeted
genome sequencing targeted sequencing
offers with excellent coverage as well
as a detailed look at what's going on in
that particular location this type of
specialized sequencing
could be you
could be useful if you wanted to find
mutation that causes a specific
condition
such as cancer with 40 to 400 genes
targeted sequencing works fast targeted
sequencing is capable for examining a
small
particular section of genome in greater
detail it gives us gene a lot of
coverage and lets us see single-based
changes like insertion and deletion
targeted sequencing also create less
data which may
make analysis easier than with some of
the larger
large scale sequencing approaches
whole exome sequencing we can we can see
all the gene changes with the whole
enzyme sequencing from single points
mutation to diverse
and deletion although entire exome
sequencing gives less coverage than
targeted sensing we learn more about a
genome folding region whole exam
frequency provides us with a wealth of
information which is both subjecting in
a problem
a complete
genome sequence of 3 billion base pair
which is comparable to whole example
this is significantly more than an
entire example
wgs generates a more detailed look at
the information in our dna by reading
both coding and non-polling systems
ngs next generation sequencing it is a
massively parallel sequencing technology
that offers ultra high throughput
scalability and weight is used to
determine the order of nucleotides in
the entire genomes or targeted systems
of dna rna there are two terms related
to
next generation sequencing those are
variant calling and sequence alignment
variant calling the variation in genome
depends with respect to choose the
sensitive thickness and alignment to
identify mutation we need to match the
reed to the reference system
epigenome is the branch of biology which
studies the character interaction
between genes and their products which
bring the phenotype into vein
three systems include dna methylenes and
histone modification and non-coding rnas
are known to pair fundamental drones in
epigenetics
dna methylation dna methylation is an
addition of methyl group to the five
carbon oxygen in the dna molecule h2o
modification are further mechanism that
regulate accessibility of chromatin for
transcription matching the stones of
protein that track and order dna
molecule inside the cell nucleus
into compact structure called nucleus
and non-coding rna classical epigenetic
mechanism include methylation of dna
host translational modification of
system
hypergenetics and disease methylation is
a well-known and commonly used
epigenetic epigenetic molecule
modification path by itself it has been
linked to a variety of human elements
including malignancy malignancies
auto-human diseases and neurological
disorders furthermore the solution may
be considered for complicated disorder
influenced by secondary factors like as
variation and age which may alter the
severity of the disorder
data set yeah the data set which was
finalized for my study was after
hepatocellular carcinoma in this paper
64 cases of hypertrophic carcinoma was
compared to 30 normal tissue and there
were various methods that were used to
compare this study the data has a
session number of gse8760
now the final interpretation of raw data
from datasets so first of all we
downloaded the file in the raw uh raw
mode and the first and after that the
raw file was converted to converted into
an annotated uh file and after that we
performed the various various
tests like t test p value
strategy test and find p value and fdr
and fold chain we will identify down
regulated g for that we need negative
value of full chain and to identify for
uh up regulation we need to find
positive value of whole chain
we will sort the fold in on descending
order and then take out the top 10 genes
in upright regulated and these top 10
genes are responsible for cancer and the
next step is we will start the folding
and hold in ascending order and then
find top 10 gene in down revolution and
take out that top 10 genes that are
related to the cancer
so here are some
top 10 up regulated genes as well as top
and down regulated team they are
sp in k1 akbr 1b10 top 2a cdc 20 and
many more
thank you very much